MONOLOGUE.
♪ SHACH SEAN HAPPY NEW YEAR
TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES.
I HAVE BEEN OFF FOR A COUPLE
OF WEEKS.
AFTER WATCHING NEWS OVER
VACATION, IT'S VERY EVIDENT,
IT IS TRANSPARENT AND IT IS
CLEAR THAT AMERICA IS FACING
THE BIGGEST INFORMATIONAL
CRISIS WE HAVE EVER FACED.
WE HAVE A DULY ELECTED PUT
OF THE UNITED STATES THAT IS
JUST TRULY HATED BY VERY
POWERFUL FORCES.
AND THEY HAVE THE UNITED
GOAL.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENCY.
AND THIS PRESIDENT.
IT IS SO BAD THAT THE
PRESIDENT, THE FIRST LADY
CAN'T EVEN VISIT OUR BRAVE
TROOPS IN IRAQ OR TALK TO
KIDS ABOUT SANTA CLAUS
WITHOUT WHAT IS BRUTAL
CHARACTER ASSASSINATION,
PERSONAL ATTACKS, AND JUST
PURE HATRED.
THIS IS WHY WE ARE
INTRODUCING NEW SEGMENTS ON
THIS PROGRAM.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THEM
HANNITY WATCH.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
HANNITY WATCH ON MEDIA BIAS
WHERE WE WILL EXPOSE ALL THE
HATRED NEWS COVERAGE.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A
HANNITY WATCH ON THE
ECONOMY.
THINGS AND HOW THEY IMPACT
YOUR FAMILY, YOUR
POCKETBOOK.
HANNITY WATCH ON HEALTHCARE.
THAT IS BEST FOR YOUR
FAMILY?
HANNITY WATCH ON HOLLYWOOD,
HOW THEY HAVE AN AGENDA THAT
IS BOTH POLITICAL AND BIASED
AND DESIGNED TO
INDOCTRINATE.
I HAVE A HANNITY WATCH ON
CAMPUS WHERE POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS AND
INDOCTRINATION OF OUR KIDS
HAS GOTTEN WAY OUT OF
CONTROL.
WE WILL HAVE HANNITY WATCH
ON THE DEEP STATE
PREDICTION, HUGE, STUNNING
NEWS.
THIS YEAR THAT WILL EXPOSED
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER,
CORRUPTION OF OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT.
I WILL HAVE HANNITY WATCH ON
SOCIALISM.
THAT MEANS THE PUSH TO
DESTROY FREE MARKET CAPITAL
I.
HANNITY WATCH ON NATIONAL
SECURITY.
HOW WHO PROTECT OUR
HOMELAND.
AND EFFORTS BY SOME TO
UNDERMINE THESE PROTECTIONS.
WE WILL HAVE HANNITY ON
BORDER SECURITY.
WE WILL BE WATCHING THERE AS
WELL.
AS THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO STOP
THE FLOW OF DRUGS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
EVERY NIGHT WE ARE GOING TO
BE ASKING THIS QUESTION IS
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
GOOD FOR AMERICA?
IS IT GOOD FOR YOU.
IS IT GOOD FOR YOUR
FAMILIES?
IS IT GOOD FOR WE, THE
PEOPLE?
WE PLAN TO EXPOSE ALL THE
HATRED THAT IS OUT THERE
EVERY DAY.
PEOPLE THAT HATE OUR
CONSTITUTION.
PEOPLE THAT WOULD SHRED OUR
BILL OF RIGHTS, FOURTH,
SECOND, THIRD AMENDMENTS.
OFFER SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT
THE INTERESTS OF EVERY
AMERICAN.
THIS IS NOT REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
THIS IS NOT CONSERVATIVE OR
LIBERAL.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT IS RIGHT
FOR THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
SO, WE BEGIN THAT'S MY
MISSION.
THE MISSION OF THIS SHOW
GOING FORWARD.
WE WANT TO LOOK OUT FOR YOU,
PROTECT YOU, PROTECT YOUR
FAMILY, FIGHT DAILY TO
ENSURE THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC STAYS STRONG AND
VIBRANT FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
AND SADLY, THAT'S AT RISK.
WE HAVE POWERFUL FORCES AND
YOU CAN SEE THEM EVERY DAY
IN SOCIETY THAT HAVE NOW
ALIGNED TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT THAT WE WE, THE
PEOPLE HAVE ELECTED.
IT'S A CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER TO EVERY AMERICAN.
WE ARE INVITING YOU IN EVERY
WEEK NIGHT AT THE:00.
I HAVE PROMISE YOU NO OTHER
SHOW ON TELEVISION LIKE
THIS.
TONIGHT WE START OUR HANNITY
WATCH REPORT ON THE HATEFUL
FORCES THAT ARE DETERMINED
TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
THEY HATE THIS PRESIDENT.
AND THEY ALSO DEEP DOWN THEY
HATE WE, THE PEOPLE THAT
VOTED FOR HIM.
THEY CAN'T BELIEVE WE MADE
THAT DECISION YOU DON'T
BELIEVE ME LISTEN TO LONG
SERVING DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN HANK JOHNSON.
THIS JUST HAPPENED
YESTERDAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AMERICANS ELECTED AN
AUTHORITARIAN ANTI-IMMIGRANT
RACIST STRONG MAN TO THE
NATION'S HIGHEST OFFICE.
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
FOLLOWERS WHO WANT TO RETURN
AMERICA BACK TO A TIME WHEN
WHITE MEN AND WHITE
PRIVILEGE WERE UNCHALLENGED.
AND WHERE MINORITIES AND
WOMEN WERE IN THEIR PLACE
MUCH LIKE HITLER TOOK OVER
THE NAZI PARTY, TRUMP HAS
TAKEN OVER THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> Tucker: THESE TYPE OF
IGNORANT HATE-FILLED
ANALOGIES ARE HAPPENING
EVERY DAY.
WHEN THEY ARE NOT COMPARING
US TO NAZIS, WELL, REMEMBER,
WE'RE THE SMELLY WALMART
PEOPLE AS FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK CALLED US OR THE
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLE THAT
HILLARY CLINTON TOLD US.
REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA REFERRED
TO US HE'S THE BITTER, ANGRY
AMERICANS THAT ACTUALLY
CLAIM TO OUR GOD, OUR GUNS,
OUR BIKES AND RELIGION.
MANY OF THESE FORCES ARE
FORCES OF HATE.
WE KNOW THAT MANY HATE THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY HATE WE, THE PEOPLE.
ON THIS SHOW WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE HAPGHT THEM
BACK.
THEM --
HATING THEM BACK.
INSTEAD EVERY NIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM HE WOULD WILL BE
EXPOSING THEM AND WHAT IS
THE CORROSIVE POLITICS OF
DIVISION.
THIS IS WHAT I CALL OUT FIVE
MAJOR FORCES OF HATE.
YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
IF DONALD TRUMP CURED CANCER
TODAY AND GAVE EVERY
AMERICAN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TODAY, EVERY ONE.
AND THISSAL STILL TRY TO
DISWOID THIS MAN.
AS HE REPRESENTS TO THEM THE
BIGGEST ON STICK KEL TO THEM
REGAINING POWER.
SECOND PERHAPS THE MOST
OBVIOUS IN AMERICA WE HAVE
THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA.
IT'S NOW ON TV EVERY
NEWSCAST EVERY SECOND OF
EVERY MINUTE OF EVERY HOUR
OF EVERY DAY.
A NEVER ENDING NONSTOP TRUMP
HATE FEST U IT'S ON A LOOP.
AND NEWSPAPERS IN THIS
COUNTRY, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO OUTDO EACH OTHER
SHOWING HOW MUCH THEY HATE
TRUMP THE MOST.
NOW, WHEN IS THE MEDIA EVER
TOLD YOU ABOUT THESE THINGS,
FOR EXAMPLE.
THIS IS WHAT HANNITY WATCH
IS ALL ABOUT.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
SUCCESS OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
WHAT ABOUT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT ARE
SCROLLING ON YOUR SCREEN
THAT WE ARE SHOWING YOU
TONIGHT.
NIGHT IN AND NIGHT OUT?
THINGS THEY NEVER TALK
ABOUT.
DON'T EXPECT THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA TO SHOW THIS REPORT
FROM REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
LOOK AT THIS, DETAILING THE
PRESIDENT'S TOP TEN
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE YEAR.
PROMISES MADE, PROMISES KEPT
U HIS HIS SUCCESSFUL
EXPHENGT GUY LIKE BRETT
KAVANAUGH LAST YEAR GOT IT
DONE FOR THE SUPREME COURT
OR THE SQUEEZE ON CHINA FOR
UNFAIR TRADE PRACTICES OR
INTELLECTUALLY PROPERTY.
INSTEESED THE HIGHEST IN 12
YEARS.
THE MIDDLE CLASS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS CLAIM TO CARE
ABOUT.
THE U.S., MEXICO, CANADA
TRADE DEAL.
ENDING THE IRANIAN NUKE
ADEAL.
TOP ACCOMPLISHMENTS 2018.
WHEN HE MOVED THE U.S.
EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM.
SMASHING ISIS.
INCREASING THE JOBS.
THE LOWEST NUMBERS
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS FOR
MINORITIES.
KEEPING MEMBERS OF THE
MIGRANT CARAVAN ARE FROM
POURING INTO THE COUNTRY.
WE CAN'T FORGET, THIS IS MY
FAVORITE.
AMERICA IS NOW THE LARGEST
OIL PRODUCING NATION NUT
BOLDER.
NOT RUSSIA.
NOT SAUDI ARABIA.
THE AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
THE PIPELINES BEING
INCREASED.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE ANWR.
THAT WILL BE MALLS OF HIGH
PAYING JOBS.
THE KEEP STATE WE ALREADY
NEURO HILLARY CLINTON PLAY
MULTIPLE FELONIES AND
VIOLATED ESPIONAGE ACT WE
KNOW SHE OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
WE KNOW SHE DESCROIFD
SUBPOENAED EMAILS, ERASED
HARD DRIVES U BROKE UP
PHONES AND BLACKBERRIES AND
iPHONES, HE IS ET CETERA
WITH WITH A HAMMER.
WE'VE KNOW PEOPLE PURPOSELY
RIG YOU HAD THE REGULATION
TO GIVE HER A PASS THAT
NOBODY ELSE IN AMERICA WOULD
EVER GET.
THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR
AMERICA.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ASKING
TONIGHT.
IS IT DANGEROUS?
THE ANSWER IS OBVIOUS.
NOW, ALL OF THIS ALLOWED
HILLARY TO CONTINUE HER
PURSUIT OF THE PRESIDENCY.
REMEMBER, THEY THOUGHT SHE
SHOULD WIN 100 MILLION TO
ZERO AND ALLOW HER TO FUNNEL
MONEY INTO A LAW FIRM.
HIRE A OP. RESEARCH FIRM AND
RUSSIAN SOURCES.
TO CREATE A DOSSIER ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S THE COLLUSION THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR BUT DON'T
WANT TO FIND.
WE, OF COURSE, HAVE THE
RUSSIAN LIES.
NEVER VERIFIED.
NEVER CORROBORATED.
THEN, DISSEMINATED TO YOU,
WE THE PEOPLE BEFORE THE
2016 ELECTION TO INFLUENCE
THE OUTCOME OF THAT ELECTION
IN HER FAVOR.
AND THOSE SAME RUSSIAN LIES
NEVER VERIFIED WERE THEN
USED BY TOP PEOPLE AT OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IN
THE FBI, IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
TO GET FOUR FISA WARRANTS TO
SPY ON A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE BOTH BEFORE AND
AFTER THE ELECTION.
ALL SIGNED OFF BY TOP
OFFICIALS.
HERE'S A QUELL TONIGHT.
IS THAT GOOD FOR AMERICA OR
IS THAT DANGEROUS FOR
AMERICA WHEN YOU HAVE FRAUD
PER TRAITED ON FISA COURT
JUDGES.
NO ARRESTS, NOBODY HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE COURT IGNORES THE BIGS
AS BECAUSE OF POWER SCANDAL
IN MODERN HISTORY.
THIS IS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
WILL BECOME A BANANA
REPUBLIC.
MIGHT AS WELL SHRED THE
CONSTITUTION BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE RENDERED.
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS ARE SIMILARLY RENDERED
MEANINGLESS.
THE KEEP STATE HAS BEEN AND
IS OUT TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT.
HATE THE PRESIDENT.
AND THEY ARE DOING IT BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY, OBVIOUSLY,
AND THAT'S BASED ON WHAT WE
KNOW TODAY.
>> .
WE HAVE WEEK WICK
WE HAVE NEEK WICK
WE HAVE NEVK WICK
WE HAVE NEVERWICK
WE HAVE NEVER TCK
WE HAVE NEVER TRUMPERSNUMBER FIV
WE HAVE NEVER TRUMPERSNUMBER FI.
THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT TO SAY SEE, WE
WERE RIGHT.
YOU WERE WRONG.
YOU NONINTELLECTUAL BLUE
COLLAR HARD-WORKING
TAX-PAYING, LAW ABIDING
AMERICANS.
DID YOU THIS TO US.
NO, THEY ARE TRYING TO
UNDERMINE A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
NOW, IMAGINE IF ANY AMERICAN
TONIGHT LIKE YOU ROBERT
MUELLER SCRUBBED THE PHONES
OF TRUMP HATERS AND RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATORS STRZOK AND
PAGE, CLEAN, WIPE THEM
CLEAN.
IMAGINE IF LIKE JAMES COMEY
THAT YOU BRAGGED ABOUT
TRICKING A 33 YEAR WAR HERO
INTO AN FBI INTERVIEW BY
BYPASSING ALL THE NORMAL
PROTOCOL AND PROCEDURES THAT
WOULD -- THAT YOU WOULD USE
IN PAST ADMINISTRATIONS.
IMAGINE THE DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR TELLING GENERAL
FLYNN HE DIDN'T NEED A
LAWYER AND THEN CHARGING HIM
FOR LYING.
ON THIS SHOW MOVING FORWARD,
WE ARE LOOKING TO PROTECT
YOU PROTECT THIS GREAT
COUNTRY AGAINST FORCES OF
HATE THAT WOULD SHRED OUR
CONSTITUTION.
THIS WILL BE YOUR SHOW.
WE WILL BE YOUR WATCHDOG.
WE PLAN TO EXPOSE ALL OF
THIS CORRUPTION.
ALL OF THESE LIES.
OH YOU MEAN LIKE HYPOCRISY
WHEN DEMOCRATS SUPPORTED
BUILDING A WALL AND DON'T
ANY LONGER BECAUSE TRUMP
WANTS ONE.
THAT THERE REALLY IS HIT IN
MIRACLE.
REAL HATE.
THAT HATE IS ALIGNS FORCES
ARE TRYING TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT AND
HATE US FOR VOTING FOR HIM.
THEY HATE TRADITIONAL CORE
CONSERVATIVE VALUES THAT WE
HOLD NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR
HEARTS.
I HAVE WILL ADMIT THIS ONE
HOUR NEWS PROGRAM TO BE VERY
BLUNT, THIS SHOW WILL BE AN
ISLAND UNTO ITSELF.
THERE ALREADY NO OTHER SHOW.
PROTECTING DEEPLY RELD
AMERICAN VALUES.
WE ARE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TAILGATING TOO
TYPICALLY TRUTH ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE COUNTRY.
NOW WE TURN OUR HANNITY
WATCH ON BORDER SECURITY
TONIGHT.
LOOK AT THIS.
A 5-MONTH-OLD BOY WILL NEVER
SEE HIS HERO FATHER AGAIN.
NEWMAN CALIFORNIA POLICE
OFFICER, LEGAL IMMIGRANT,
RONIL SINGH VICIOUSLY
MURDERED BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT WITH A VERY LONG
CRIMINAL TRACK RECORD AND
TIES TO VIOLENT GANGS.
NOW, THE COUNTY SHERIFF ADAM
CHRISTIANSON SAID THAT THIS
HORRIFIC CRIME DO NOT HAVE
HAPPENED -- WOULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED IF NOT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CATCH AND
RELEASE SANCTUARY CITY
STATUS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I SIMPLY WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
CRIMINAL, ILLEGAL ALIEN WITH
PRIOR CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO
ICE.
WE WERE PREDICTED, LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS PREDICTED
BECAUSE OF SANCTUARY LAWS
AND THAT LED TO THE
ENCOUNTER WITH OFFICER SING.
I'M SUGGESTING THAT THE
OUTCOME COULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT IF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WASN'T RESTRICTED,
PROHIBITED, OR HAD THEIR
HANDS TIED BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL INTERFERENCE.
>> Sean: HANDS TIED BECAUSE
OF POLITICAL INTERFERENCE.
SHERIFF CHRISTIANSON IS
GOING TO BE WITH US TONIGHT
IN JUST A MOMENT.
IT'S VERY CLEAR CALIFORNIA'S
FAR LEFT LAWMAKERS ARE NOT
LISTENING TOUT CITIZENS OF
THEIR OWN STATE.
WE SENT LAWRENCE JONES TO
CALIFORNIA TO SEE WHAT
CALIFORNIANS REALLY THINK
ABOUT THAT STATE'S SANCTUARY
POLICIES.
REMEMBER, THEY HAVE
CRIMINALS THAT SHOULD BE I
DO PORTED AND HANDED
DO -ORTED AND HANDED
DO --RTED AND HANDED
DO -- DED AND HANDED
DO -- DEP AND HANDED
DO -- DEPORND HANDED
DO -- DEPORTE HANDED
DO -- DEPORTEDHANDED
DO -- DEPORTED ANDED
DO -- DEPORTED AND HANDED
OVER TO ICE.
THEY SET THEM FREENCHTS A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE BLAMING
THE CALIFORNIA SANCTUARY
STATE POLICIES.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT.
>> I THINK IT'S THE WORST
THING CALIFORNIA HAS DONNA
LONG TIME.
>> I'M NOT A BIG WALL
PERSON.
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK A SANCTUARY STATE
IS CRAZY.
SANCTUARY CITY POLICY IS THE
STUPIDEST THING THAT
DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE EVER
DONE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Jon: WE WILL SHOW YOU
MORE.
WHAT HAPPENED IN NULAND,
CALIFORNIA IS ALL TOO COMMON
OCCURRENCE.
OVER THE WEEKEND A
22-YEAR-OLD MAN IN
KNOXVILLE, TENNESSEE KILLED
BY SUSPECTED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT WHO CRASHED INTO
ONCOMING TRAFFIC.
THREE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INDICTED FOR THE MURDER OF A
MAN LIVING IN LONG ISLAND.
SO MANY LIES HAVE BEEN
SENSELESSLY LOST AT THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO NEVER
SHOULD HAVE EVER BEEN IN
THIS COUNTRY EVER ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
LET ME SAY THESE STATISTICS
REALLY SLOW SO EVEN NANCY
PELOSI, WHO DOESN'T WANT TO
FUND A WALL AND PROTECTED
BORDERS SHE CAN
UNDERSTANDING.
SINCE 2014, 51 MURDER
CONVICTIONS HAVE BEEN HANDED
DOWN TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
228 FEDERAL ASSAULT
SENTENCES.
NEARLY 20,000 DRUG
TRAFFICKING SENTENCES.
ON THE STATE LEVEL IT'S EVEN
WORSE.
ACCORDING TO THE GAO AND
THEIR ESTIMATES SINCE 17964,
27,300 ARRESTS FOR MURDER
HAVE BEEN CARRIED OUGHT BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
OVER 120,000 SEX OFFENSES.
NEAR LIVER 400,000 ATAUGHT
CHARGES.
OVER 1,000 ACTS OF TERROR.
HERE'S A TOUGH QUESTION.
I WANT PEOPLE TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THIS.
IF PEOPLE KEEP GETTING
KILLED, THIS 5-MONTH-OLD BOY
WILL NEVER SEE HIS FATHER,
HIS FATHER THE HERO THAT GOT
KILLED THIS WEEKEND, BECAUSE
WOULD HAVE PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY, WE KNOW THEY ARE
HERE ILLEGALLY.
THEY COMMIT OTHER CRIMES.
WE DON'T HAND THEM OVER TO
ICE, WE WON'T ENFORCE UFT
LAW AND DO PORT THEM, WELL,
IS CONGRESS GOING TO PAY TO
RAISE THE CHILDREN OF THOSE
KILLED LIKE IN THE CASE OF
THIS CALIFORNIA OFFICER?
WILL CONGRESS PAY FOR THE
CHILDREN'S CHIMG EDUCATION?
WILL THEY AT LEAST PAY FOR
THE PIEWRNL?
AT SOME POINT THEY BEAR SOME
OF THE BURDEN BECAUSE THESE
FAILED GOVERNMENT POLICIES
ARE NOW AIDING AND ABETTING
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAPPEN.
IF WE ENFORCE THE LAW.
IF WE PROTECTED OUR BORDERS.
AND NANCY PELOSI AND HER
FELLOW DEMOCRATS THEY ARE
NOW WILLING TO SHUTT DOWN
THE GOVERNMENT TO PREVENT
EVEN A PARTIAL FUNDING OF A
BORDER WALL THAT PROTECTS
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
NOW THIS WALL IS DESIGNED TO
GIVE BORDER AGENTS MORE
TIMPLE THAT WANT TO
APPREHEND THOSE WHO WANT TO
CROSS ILLEGALLY.
I WILL BE THE FIRST TO
CONCEDE VAST 99% WHO WANT TO
CROSS IN YOU'RE ON CAN I TRI
ARE LOOKING FOR BETTER LIFE
FOR THEMSELVES THEIR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN AND
OPPORTUNITY THEY DON'T HAVE
IN THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A LIGHT TO NOE WHO
IS COMING INTO IN COUNTRY.
WE SUPPORT LEGAL IMMIGRATION
ON NEW YEAR'S EVE 150
INDIVIDUALS VIDEO.
BREAK ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S
BORDER WITH MEXICO.
AGAIN, ROCKS OTHER
PROJECTILES THROWN AT BORDER
AGENTS.
KEEP IN MIND THOSE WHO
SUCCESSFULLY CROSS OUR
BORDER ILLEGALLY ON AVERAGE,
IF THEY GET ACROSS, CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM, HEALTHCARE SYSTEM,
IT'S COSTING WE, THE
TAXPAYERS AROUND $70,000 PER
PERSON.
EVEN TOP DEMOCRATS A FEW
YEARS AGO REALIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF STEMMING THE
TIDE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
MANY OF THEM SOUNDED LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I VOTED NUMEROUS TIMES
WHEN I WAS A SENATOR TO
SPEND MONEY TO BUILD A
BARRIER TO TRY TO PREVENT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM
COMING FROM.
AND I DO THINK YOU HAVE TO
CONTROL YOUR BORDERS.
>> PEOPLE WHO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT OUR
PERMISSION ARE ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND ILLEGAL ALIENS
SHOULD NOT BE TREATED THE
SAME AS PEOPLE WHO ENTERED
THE U.S. LEGALLY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
NEVER ACCEPT IMMIGRATION
REFORM UNLESS THEY TRULY
BELIEVE THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT IS COMMITTED TO
ENDING FUTURE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> THOSE WHO ENTER OUR
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND THOSE
WHO EMPLOY THEM DISRESPECT
THE RULE OF LAW.
AND BECAUSE WE LIVE IN AN
AGE WHERE TERRORISTS ARE
CHALLENGING OUR BORDERS, WE
CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO POUR
INTO THE U.S. UNDETECTED,
UNDOCUMENTED, AND UNCHECKED.
>> Sean: THEY SOUNDED LIKE
TRUMP.
NOW BECAUSE TRUMP WANTS IT,
THEY DON'T WANT IT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS PATTERN IS IMPORTANT.
IT'S ABOUT SAVING LIVES.
IT'S ABOUT STOPPING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND DRUG
TRAFFICKING AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THE PRESIDENT MUST STAY
STRONG ON HIS PROMISE GET
THAT CALL FULLY BUILD.
THEY STARTED OF WITH YOU BUT
THEY HAVE MORE.
I WOULD CONSIDER THIS A
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE.
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
VANTAGE POINT HE COULD
ALLOCATE $5 BILLION FROM THE
MILITARY BUDGET AND GET THE
JOB DONE.
GOVERNMENT STAYS SHUT DOWN.
ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
DON'T LET THE MEDIA SCARE
YOU THAT CONTINUES.
SOCIAL SECURITY CHECK ALSO
GO OUT.
THE COAST GUARD IS ON DUTY.
OUR MILITARY BRANCHES ARE ON
DUTY AND THE PEOPLE WILL BE
TAKEN CARE OF.
BUT THE COST OF UNFETTERED
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
TOO HIGH.
THE RISKS ARE TOO GREAT.
>> HOW WOULD YOU FEEL NEW
EVERYWHERE FAMILY MEMBER OF
THE OFFICER 5
THE OFFICER MONTH OLD SON
KILLED THIS WEEKEND.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF LIFE AND
DEAF.
DRUGS HEADED TO SMALL TOWNS
AND BIG CITIES ALL ACROSS
AMERICA.
TO MY WEAK REPUBLICAN
FRIENDS IN WASHINGTON.
HOLD THE LINE HAVE A
BACKBONE, HAVE A SPINE, YOU
ARE THERE TO SERVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE MUST GIVE OUR BORDER
AGENTS THE TOOLS THEY NEED,
INCLUDING THE WALL SO THEY
CAN END HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
DRUG TRAFFICKING, VIOLENT
CRIMINALS, EACH SOME
TERRORISTS OR ANYBODY ELSE
WHO PLANS TO BREAK OUR LAWS
AND HURT OUR FELLOW AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
WE SUPPORT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
ON THIS PROGRAM REPUBLICAN,
DEMOCRAT, I DON'T CARE.
WE WILL CALL YOU OUT,
ESPECIALLY REPUBLICANS WHO
DON'T HOLD THE LINE AND FUND
A BORDER WALL.
THIS IS WORTH FIGHTING FOR.
AND BY THE WAY THE PRESIDENT
HAS PROMISED TO MAKE MEXICO
PAY FOR THE WALL.
>> HE ACTUALLY GOING TO
WRITE A CHECK?
WE HAVE HANNITY ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU DON'T EXPECT HE IS
GOING TO WRITE A CHECK.
WHAT YOU ARE SAY SOMETHING
THEY HAVE TO MAKE
CONCESSIONS.
>> THERE IS MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS.
>> Sean: YOU DON'T EXPECT
$10 MILLION.
>> IT WOULDN'T LOOK GOOD.
>> Sean: DEALS YOU MAKE
WOULD MORE THAN CON PEN SAY
FOR THE WALL.
>> EACH IF WE TAX THEM.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
DIFFERENCE.
>> WE HAVE MORE ON THIS
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S TURN OUR
ATTENTION JUST BRIEFLY TO
MITT ROMNEY.
HE HAS NOT BEEN SWORN IN AS
SENATOR.
AND ROMNEY IS ALREADY
LAUNCHING A FECKLESS ATTACK
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT,
FOLLOWING HIS OP-ED SLAMMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
SO-CALLED CHARACTER AND
LEADERSHIP ISSUES.
WELL, THE RNC CHAIRWOMAN,
RONNA MCDANIEL, HIS NIECE,
TWEETED WELL, FOR AN
INCOMING REPUBLICAN FRESHMAN
CENTER
SENTER
SENAER
SENATOR TO ATTACK PRESIDENT
TRUMP AS THEIR FIRST ACT
FEEDS INTO WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ANDTH MEDIA WANT.
IT'S DISAPPOINTING AND
UNREPUBLICAN TIA.
OUR FRIEND THE GREAT ONE
MARK LEVIN ISSUING IT'S
CLEAR ROMFULLY WOULD BE
FORCE IN THE SENATE PLAYING
TO THE MEDIA PRAISE HIM AND
SEEKING A PRESIDENCY.
I SUPPORTED MITT ROMNEY.
THAT HE WAS THE SAME MEDIA
THAT BEIRUTIZE DOLLARS HIM
IN 2012.
IT'S SAD HE HAS MORE
INTEREST IN CLOSING UP FOR
THOSE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT WHO
HATED HIM THAN STICKING UP
FOR PROTECTING AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
AMERICAN INDEPENDENCE.
SECURING OUR BORDERS, INCHES
ISSUES HE CLAIMS TO CARE
ABOUT.
DEMOCRATS PURSUE RADICAL